This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1928, a strange phenomenon was sweeping the state of Idaho, a vanishing act of sorts. A poise resident would wake up on a typical Monday morning, drag themselves out of bed, get dressed for the day, and they would hop in their car to drive to work, not noticing that something was missing. And suddenly, cops in the rear view. And the next thing that the driver of the car knew, they were getting picked up because they weren't displaying an license plate. Idaho's historian Rick Just says license plates, well, they were disappearing.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1928年，爱达荷州正在席卷一种奇怪的现象，某种程度上的消失行为。一个稳重的居民会在一个平常的周一早晨醒来，把自己从床上拖起来，穿好衣服去上班，然后他们会跳上车去上班，没有注意到少了什么。突然间，后视镜里出现了警察。车里的司机接下来知道的是，他们被拦下来了，因为他们没有悬挂车牌。爱达荷州历史学家里克·贾斯特说，车牌，嗯，它们正在消失。
The Secretary of State was fielding complaints about all the lost tags. And soon enough, the culprit became clear. Tourists would come to Idaho and steal the plates. Idaho's license plates were being snatched up like plush hotel bathrooms. Yeah, yeah. People would come up, but they would pull up to either a tourist park or a motel or something, and they would spot those plates
州务卿一直在处理关于所有丢失标签的投诉。很快，罪魁祸首就水落石出了。游客会来到爱达荷州并偷走车牌。爱达荷州的车牌就像豪华酒店的毛巾一样被抢购一空。是的，是的。人们会开车过来，把车停在旅游公园、汽车旅馆或者类似的地方，然后他们会盯上那些车牌
and think, you know, I'd like to have a souvenir. And so they would just take it off of the car and take it home. And there was a reason why people couldn't resist swiping Idaho plates in particular. That year, the state had revolutionized license plate design. That's reporter Daniel Akramin. Before this, plates were basic, with info like the state name and the registration numbers. All of this on a pretty simple solid colored background. But in 1928, the Secretary of State in Idaho had an epiphany. He was like, we have this half-square
心想，你知道的，我想要一个纪念品。于是他们就会直接把它从车上卸下来，带回家。人们无法抗拒顺走爱达荷州车牌的原因有一个特定的原因。那一年，该州彻底革新了车牌设计。那是记者丹尼尔·阿克拉明。在此之前，车牌都很基础，带有州名和注册号等信息。所有这些都在一个相当简单的纯色背景上。但在1928年，爱达荷州的州务卿有了一个顿悟。他当时想，我们有半平方
foot of open real estate just rolling around on everyone's cars. Let's do something with it. The 1928 plate is often said to be the very first advertising license plate in the country. They're the very first one that tried to advertise a product. In the product that Idaho chose, we'll surprise absolutely no one. The state's 1928 license plates all featured a single giant potato. That big kind of elongated goofy looking potato, but big. It was as big as the plate. The registration numbers were stamped in green lettering,
英尺的空置房地产在每个人的车上晃悠。让我们用它做点什么吧。1928年的车牌通常被称为该国第一个广告车牌。它们是第一个试图宣传产品的车牌。爱达荷州选择的产品，绝对不会让任何人感到惊讶。该州1928年的车牌都印着一个巨大的土豆。那种又大又长、看起来有点滑稽的土豆，但很大。它和车牌一样大。注册号码是用绿色字母印上去的，
right on top of this lumpy brown spot. I would say it looks almost fecal in nature. It does. It really, the shape, particularly, yes, yes. The execution wasn't perfect, but it was innovative. Below the tremendous tater, there was even a modest, pragmatic slogan. Idaho potatoes. Today, every state's got a marketing slogan. Hawaii is the Aloha State, Missouri is the
就在这个肿块状的棕色斑点正上方。我会说它看起来几乎带有粪便的性质。确实如此。是的，它的形状，特别是，是的，是的。执行得并不完美，但它具有创新性。在这颗巨大的土豆下面，甚至还有一个朴素、务实的标语。爱达荷土豆。今天，每个州都有一个营销标语。夏威夷是阿罗哈州，密苏里州是
Showme State, but Idaho was the first to put theirs on a license plate. They wanted to make sure that when people thought about Idaho, they thought potatoes. And for better or worse, the association stuck. And now it's gotten to be such a thing. I mean, coming out here in a few days, it's a New Year's Eve, we drop a potato. What do you mean? Absolutely. Well, you know how the Times Square ball comes floating down
展现州，但爱达荷州是第一个把他们的标语印在车牌上的。他们想确保当人们想到爱达荷州时，就会想到土豆。不管好坏，这个联系一直存在。现在这已经成了一件大事。我的意思是，几天后来到这里，那是除夕夜，我们会扔下一个土豆。你什么意思？当然。嗯，你知道时代广场的水晶球是如何漂浮下来
like that. Well, we have a big potato that comes floating down. They've been doing it about 10 years now. The concept of slapping a tagline onto a license plate might not seem like a big deal, but it turns out this idea would end up having outsized consequences and not just for Idaho. We're talking legislative clashes, multiple Supreme Court cases, and even jail time. Because what started in one state would soon spread, and when it did, the question of what should go on a license plate and what shouldn't would prove surprisingly contentious.
那样的。嗯，我们有一个巨大的土豆漂浮下来。他们已经这样做大约十年了。在车牌上贴上标语的概念可能看起来不是什么大事，但事实证明，这个主意最终会产生超乎寻常的后果，而且不仅仅是对爱达荷州而言。我们谈论的是立法冲突、多起最高法院案件，甚至还有牢狱之灾。因为从一个州开始的事物很快就会蔓延开来，当它蔓延时，车牌上应该印什么和不应该印什么的问题被证明是出奇地具有争议性。
The first state issued license plates appeared at the very beginning of the 20th century, and they served a mostly bureaucratic function. More people were buying and crashing cars every year, so state governments originally mandated plates as a way to keep track of all the nuts behind the wheel. No one was interested in sloganering. But then Americans discovered the road trip. The U.S.A. in your Chevrolet. Well, the big factor with increase in automobiles
第一个由州发行的车牌出现在20世纪初期的刚开始，它们主要履行官僚职能。每年有越来越多的人买车并撞车，所以州政府最初强制要求车牌作为跟踪方向盘后所有疯子的手段。没有人对搞标语感兴趣。但随后美国人发现了公路旅行。雪佛兰里的美国。嗯，汽车增加的一个重要因素
was that it allowed people freedom to roam. You could go wherever you wanted. Christine Byron is a former history librarian at the Grand Rapids Public Library. She focuses on the history of tourism, and she says that the rise of the road trip in the 1920s created this huge new tourist market. Drivers needed services like gas stations and roadside motels that hadn't existed in the age of steam-powered travel. Traveling east, traveling west. When you traveled by a steamship or railroad,
是它赋予了人们四处游荡的自由。你可以去任何你想去的地方。克莉丝汀·拜伦是的大急流城公共图书馆的前历史图书管理员。她专注于旅游史，她说20世纪20年代公路旅行的兴起创造了这个巨大的新旅游市场。司机需要加油站和路边汽车旅馆等在蒸汽动力旅行时代并不存在的服务。向东旅行，向西旅行。当你乘坐汽船或铁路旅行时，
you pretty much brought what you needed with you. And your meals were served at a resort. But once the automobile came along, there was a lot more money that needed to be spent. From the state's perspective, all those new tourist dollars were up for grabs. So states started letting the world know what they had to offer. Arizona had the Grand Canyon. Minnesota, it's lakes.
你基本上随身携带了你需要的东西。你的饭菜是在度假村里享用的。但一旦汽车出现，就有更多的钱需要花。从该州的角度来看，所有这些新的旅游资金都是唾手可得的。因此，各州开始让世界了解他们能提供什么。亚利桑那州有大峡谷。明尼苏达州，它的湖泊。
New Mexico, it's average 310 days of sunshine per year. And in this war for tourists, states promoted themselves anywhere they could. National magazines, various automobile guides, the blue guide, the green book, and of course tons and tons of promotional brochures. But no one thought to advertise on a license plate until 1928 when Idahoans realized
新墨西哥州，它每年平均有310天的阳光。在这场争夺游客的战争中，各州在任何可能的地方宣传自己。国家杂志、各种汽车指南、蓝色指南、绿皮书，当然还有成吨成吨的宣传册。但直到1928年，当爱达荷州人意识到
that their plates were too valuable to waste on just a registration number. And Rick just says once Idaho staked its starchy flag on the license plate, the rush was on. License plates became a different thing because of that potato. States spent the middle of the century transforming their plates from austere government documents into colorful boosters of tourism and industry. You could even think of them as miniature little a's that are driving all over the state and all over the country, hopefully.
他们的车牌太珍贵了，不能白白浪费在注册号上时，才有人想到在车牌上做广告。里克·贾斯特说，一旦爱达荷州在车牌上插上了这面淀粉质的旗帜，热潮就开始了。因为那个土豆，车牌变成了一种不同的东西。本世纪中叶，各州将车牌从简朴的政府文件转变为旅游业和工业的彩色助推器。你甚至可以把它们想象成微型的微型广告牌，在全州乃至全国各地驾驶，希望如此。
In 1940, Arizona stamped Grand Canyon State on its plates and never looked back. In 1950, Minnesota went with land of 10,000 lakes. Meanwhile, New Mexico actually put sunshine state on its plates in 1932, before Florida muscled it on the slogan in 1949. Florida for the record only has an average of 237 days of sunshine per year, but whatever. Wisconsin was America's dearing land, Maine was vacation land. Other states couldn't make up their minds. Michigan's plate, for example, initially sported the phrase water wonderland in 1954,
1940年，亚利桑那州在车牌上印上了大峡谷州，并且再也没有回头。1950年，明尼苏达州选择了1万个湖泊之地。与此同时，新墨西哥州实际上在1932年就把阳光州印在了车牌上，而在1949年佛罗里达州强行抢走了这个标语之前。据记录，佛罗里达州平均每年只有237天的阳光，但不管怎样。威斯康星州是美国的乳酪之地，缅因州是度假胜地。其他州拿不定主意。例如，密歇根州的车牌最初在1954年带有水上仙境的短语，
which then evolved into winter water wonderland, followed by Great Lakes State, Great Lakes, and Great Lakes Blender. In 1970, Michigan State Tourism Council actually adopted the slogan, the Michigan's, the almost islands of the Great Lakes. But sadly, that plate never happened. Today, license plates like these are a national institution, and it's fun in a kitschy Americana kind of way. Each state is earnestly trying to put his best foot forward. So what could possibly be wrong here?
后来演变成冬季水上仙境，接着是五大湖州、五大湖，以及五大湖奇观。1970年，密歇根州旅游委员会实际上采用了密歇根州是五大湖的几乎岛屿这一标语。但遗憾的是，那个车牌从未实现。今天，像这样的车牌已经成为一个国家机构，以一种俗气的美国风情来看很有趣。每个州都在真诚地展现最好的一面。那这里到底会有什么问题呢？
It turns out quite a bit. is earnestly trying to put his best foot forward. So what could possibly be wrong here? It turns out quite a bit. Because as fun as some of these plates might have been, at half a square foot, a license plate is a small canvas. And when you have to pick one symbol to represent an entire state, you are not going to please everyone. And this has caused trouble from the get go. In 1928, when Idaho unleashed the potato plates, it didn't go over all that well. People they tested those license plates. Lots of Idahoans, it turned out,
事实证明，问题还真不少。是在真诚地展现最好的一面。那这里到底会有什么问题呢？事实证明，问题还真不少。因为尽管其中一些车牌可能很有趣，但在半平方英尺的面积上，车牌是一个很小的画布。当你要挑选一个符号来代表整个州时，你不可能取悦所有人。这从一开始就惹出了麻烦。1928年，当爱达荷州推出土豆车牌时，反响并不是很好。人们对这些车牌进行了测试。事实证明，许多爱达荷州人
resented, being associated with the state's cash crop. Particularly people from Northern Idaho, because they don't grow potatoes up there. It really gets a kind of a southeastern Idaho thing. Newspaper editorials called it an embarrassment. One headline actually read, Why Bring That Up. And probably it's a good thing that they just dropped the idea entirely and went back to numbers in 1929. No motto, no graphics, and certainly no potatoes. And license plate quarrels weren't unique to Idaho.
怨恨与该州的经济作物联系在一起。特别是来自爱达荷州北部的人，因为他们那里不长土豆。这实际上成了爱达荷州东南部的一种东西。报纸社论称其为一种尴尬。一个头条新闻实际上写道，为什么要提起这个。可能完全放弃这个主意并在1929年回归数字是一个好主意。没有座右铭，没有图形，当然也没有土豆。车牌争吵并非爱达荷州独有。
Florida had to dump one of its plate designs after residents complained that the great fruit with a stem attached looked more like a bomb. Massachusetts, meanwhile, tried to put a codfish right next to its state's name, only to be blamed by fishermen for a poor catch that year, because the fish on the plate was swimming away from the word Massachusetts. These dust-ups over license plate design can seem like small potatoes, but the fight over license plates was about to be taken to the next level. Thanks to a politician named Meljum Thompson. In this critical battle for the survival of America,
佛罗里达州在居民抱怨带有茎的美味水果看起来更像一枚炸弹后，不得不抛弃其中一个车牌设计。与此同时，马萨诸塞州试图在州名旁边放上一条鳕鱼，结果却被渔民指责那一年的渔获量不好，因为车牌上的鱼正在游离马萨诸塞州这个词。这些关于车牌设计的争执可能看起来是小菜一碟，但关于车牌的争斗即将被推向一个新的水平。多亏了一位名叫梅尔金·汤普森的政治家。在这场关乎美国生存的关键战役中，
we shall not tolerate a no-win settlement. Thompson was a titan of New Hampshire politics in the 1970s. He served three terms as governor, and he was a conservative fire brand who hated Democrats. We must drive from the seats of power in the White House Congress and the State Department, all of the foul brood of Kami lovers. Thompson had a lot of unorthodox ideas, including wanting to arm the New Hampshire National Guard with nuclear weapons. And he was obsessed with freedom.
我们绝不容忍没有赢家的协议。汤普森是20世纪70年代新罕布什尔州政坛的泰斗。他担任过三届州长，是一个痛恨民主党的保守派狂热分子。我们必须把白宫、国会和国务院权力宝座上所有那些令人作呕的共产党爱好者赶出去。汤普森有很多不合常规的想法，包括希望用核武器武装新罕布什尔州国民警卫队。他痴迷于自由。
Here's Thompson's Dorky campaign song. Live Free or Die, of course, is New Hampshire's fiery state motto. It was coined by a revolutionary war vet. And Thompson loved it so much that before he became governor, he worked with allies in the state legislature to get it slapped on every car in the state. And I don't know of any more prominent place to carry a message than right on the license plate.
这是汤普森古怪的竞选歌曲。不自由毋宁死，当然是新罕布什尔州激昂的州座右铭。它是由一位独立战争老兵创造的。汤普森非常喜欢它，以至于在他成为州长之前，他与州议会里的盟友合作，把它印在了该州每一辆车上。我不知道有什么比车牌上更能突出地承载信息的了。
That's the best bill board at all. In 1971, the slogan on the state's license plate changed from scenic New Hampshire to live for your die. Let's be your die, don't look for freedom, pass you by, stand up. But not everyone embraced the state's message. I have to, that's ridiculous. At 88 years old, George Maynard still gets heated about the New Hampshire license plate.
这绝对是最好的广告牌。1971年，该州车牌上的标语从风景秀丽的新罕布什尔州变为了不自由毋宁死。让我们不自由毋宁死，不要看着自由，从你身边溜走，站起来。但并不是所有人都接受该州的信息。我不得不说，这太荒谬了。88岁的乔治·梅纳德对新罕布什尔州的车牌依然充满激情。
And for good reason, it changed the course of his life. George grew up in Rhode Island. He married a woman, Maxine, who he'd actually met in junior high. They settled into a pretty typical family life. They had kids. George got a job as a newspaper printer, and then something happened, like really abruptly.
而且理由充分，它改变了他的人生轨迹。乔治在罗德岛长大。他娶了一位名叫玛克辛的女子，他们实际上是在初中时认识的。他们过上了相当典型的家庭生活。他们有了孩子。乔治找到了一份报纸印刷工的工作，然后发生了一些事情，非常突然。
In 1956, four years after I got married, the witnesses came to my house. They told me that God had a name, and his name was Jehovah. George and his family joined the Jehovah's Witnesses. And by 1972, they had moved to Claremont, New Hampshire. That's where the trouble started. Every day, George would hop in his car
1956年，我结婚四年后，见证人来到了我家。他们告诉我上帝有一个名字，他的名字叫耶和华。乔治和他的家人加入了耶和华见证人会。到1972年，他们已经搬到了新罕布什尔州的克莱蒙特。麻烦就是从那里开始的。每天，乔治都会跳上车
and drive to work at the local printing press with his New Hampshire license plates screaming in all caps, live free or die. In this really great it on George, because he didn't share Meljyn Thompson's belief of freedom over everything. As a Jehovah's Witness, George actually believed that God-given life was more important than freedom. Well, that's right, definitely. And the real existence of life is very precious. Life is a gift,
开车去当地的印刷厂上班，他车上的新罕布什尔州车牌以全大写字母尖叫着“不自由毋宁死”。这真的让乔治很抓狂，因为他并不分享梅尔金·汤普森关于自由高于一切的信仰。作为一名耶和华见证人，乔治实际上认为上帝赋予的生命比自由更重要。嗯，没错，绝对的。而生命的真实存在是非常珍贵的。生命是一份礼物，
and we appreciate it very much. George didn't want the government telling him what to die for. So then one day I decided, you know, if it's offensive, why should be forced to support something that's offensive? So I carved it up with Rick Tate. And when he erased the state motto, George marched to the front lines of the license plate wars. Covering up the slogan was a violation of state law, but a few weeks went by and not much happened.
我们非常珍惜它。乔治不想让政府告诉他为什么而死。所以有一天我决定，你知道的，如果这是冒犯性的，为什么要被迫支持冒犯性的东西呢？于是我用胶带把它粘了起来。当他擦掉州座右铭时，乔治走到了车牌战争的最前线。掩盖标语违反了州法，但几周过去了，并没有发生什么大事。
Until one day, George and Maxine were shopping. They left the store, they got to their car in the parking lot, and they saw a police officer writing them a ticket. George told me he'd been expecting this for a while. He didn't actually feel scared or surprised. Well, I was happy. You were happy?
直到有一天，乔治和玛克辛在购物。他们离开商店，走到停车场他们的车前，看到一个警察在给他们开罚单。乔治告诉我，他对此已经期待一段时间了。他实际上并没有感到害怕或惊讶。嗯，我很高兴。你很高兴？
Yeah, because I was expressing my belief, my rejection of something. George refused to pay the $25 ticket. And of course, I kept the tape on, I did it again. The tickets piled up until his consistent refusal to pay landed him in court, and the judge put him away for 15 days. And so if you don't want to live for your day, you're going to jail in New Hampshire.
对，因为我在表达我的信仰，我对某事物的拒绝。乔治拒绝支付25美元的罚单。当然，我一直贴着胶带，我又做了一次。罚单堆积如山，直到他持续拒绝付款把他送进了法庭，法官判了他15天监禁。所以如果你不想不自由毋宁死，你在新罕布什尔州就要入狱。
Two weeks may not seem like hard time, but the sentence had a huge impact on George's life. When he didn't show up for work, he got fired. And he was embarrassed that his kids had to see him hauled away. Things were tough for the Maynards. But George still wasn't on fighting. With the help of the American Civil Liberties Union, he filed suit in New Hampshire, claiming the state's law prohibiting the all-train-of-licence plates was unconstitutional. And the state court agreed, but Meldrum lived for your die,
两周可能看起来不算漫长的刑期，但这个判决对乔治的生活产生了巨大影响。当他没有去上班时，他被解雇了。而且他感到尴尬的是，他的孩子们不得不看着他被带走。梅纳德一家的日子很艰难。但乔治仍在继续战斗。在美国公民自由联盟的帮助下，他在新罕布什尔州提起诉讼，声称该州禁止改装车牌的法律违宪。州法院表示赞同，但梅尔金·不自由毋宁死
Thompson, had become governor by then, and Thompson was not inclined to extend George the freedom to cover up his beloved motto. So Thompson appealed the case. We'll hear arguments next in... All the way to the US Supreme Court. 75, 14, 53.uss, Maynard. The license plates collided with the First Amendment before the High Court in November of 1976. During oral arguments, George Maynard's lawyer claimed that in covering up live for your
汤普森当时已经成为了州长，汤普森并不倾向于给予乔治掩盖他深爱的座右铭的自由。于是汤普森提起了上诉。我们接下来将听取辩论... 一路打到了美国最高法院。75年，第14案，第53号。美国诉梅纳德案。1976年11月，车牌在最高法院与第一修正案发生碰撞。在口头辩论中，乔治·梅纳德的律师声称，通过掩盖“不自由毋宁死”，
die, George was just exercising his freedom of expression. License plates are displayed on people's private vehicles. He argued the government can't just hijack that space and force people to express a certain viewpoint. And it's our position that the state lacks the power to require its citizens to bear this sort of model. I think that if the court were to uphold this sort of thing, then the state could require all citizens to wear a pin or an arm band, or they could require you to have a plaque
乔治只是在行使他的言论自由权。车牌展示在人们的私人车辆上。他辩称，政府不能只是劫持这个空间并强加给人们表达某种观点的义务。我们的立场是，国家缺乏要求其公民承担这种模式的权力。我认为，如果法院维持这种做法，那么国家可以要求所有公民佩戴一枚胸针或臂章，或者他们可以要求你在门上地址旁边的牌子上写上
on your door next to your address saying, live for your die. New Hampshire countered with, what's the big deal? Just because it's on the license plate doesn't mean every driver believes in it. And sometimes it seemed like the court was buying it, like just as they're good Marshall. The first time I noticed the motto was buying it, like just as they're good Marshall. So what was it? Was a license plate a declaration of the state's ideology or just a thing that says nothing at all since everybody had one? George couldn't make it to DC for the ruling. He actually found out the same way as everyone else. From CBS News headquarters in New York, this is the CBS evening news with Walter Cronkite.
“不自由毋宁死”。新罕布什尔州反驳说，这有什么大不了的？仅仅因为它在车牌上并不意味着每个驾驶员都相信它。有时法院似乎接受了这一点，就像大法官瑟古德·马歇尔一样。我第一次注意到这个座右铭是接受了这一点，就像大法官瑟古德·马歇尔一样。所以是什么？车牌是国家意识形态的宣言，还是仅仅是一个什么也没说的东西，因为每个人都有一个？乔治没能去华盛顿特区参加裁决。他实际上和所有人一样，通过同样的方式知道了结果。来自纽约的CBS新闻总部，这是沃尔特·克朗凯特主持的CBS晚间新闻。
Supreme Court ruled today that drivers may not be compelled to disperse. Frank I came on a nose and says that Supreme Court ruled, is our favorite that you can tape over the state bottles. That was nice. The court in effect gave them permission to tape over the offensive words. I think the court got it right in the major case. Caroline Mala Corbin is a First Amendment scholar at the University of Miami.
最高法院今天裁定，不得强迫驾驶员传播。弗兰克·艾康纳莫斯说最高法院裁定，对我们有利的是你可以用胶带贴住州的座右铭。那太好了。法院实际上批准了他们用胶带盖住那些冒犯性词汇的权限。我认为法院在这个重大案件中做对了。卡罗琳·马拉·科尔宾是迈阿密大学的第一修正案学者。
She says the court's six three decision hinged on a concept called compelled speech. The First Amendment protects both your right to speak, so it protects you against government censorship. But the free speech clause also protects your right not to speak. So it protects you against the government forcing you to say an ideological message that you disagree with. And that was what the problem was here.
她表示，法院以六比三做出的裁决取决于一个名为“被迫言论”的概念。第一修正案既保护你说话的权利，因此它保护你免受政府审查。但言论自由条款也保护你不说话的权利。因此它保护你免受政府强迫你说出你不同意的意识形态信息的侵害。这就是这里的问题所在。
They were trying to force you to say something that you don't want to say and you don't want to live by. In George's homemade solution, that strip of red tape, it actually held up under the weight of the First Amendment. And so that's my way of expressing my free speech. At this point, it might seem like George Maynard's case solved the license plate problem. Today, if you live in, say, New Jersey and object to the notion that you live in the garden state, well, you can cover that sucker up. Your car is not a government billboard on wheels. But it turns out the constitutional battle over license
他们试图强迫你说出你不想说且不想遵循的话。在乔治自制的解决方案中，那条红胶带实际上经受住了第一修正案的考验。所以这是我表达言论自由的方式。在这一点上，乔治·梅纳德的案子似乎解决了车牌问题。今天，如果你住在新泽西州，并且反对你住在花园州的观念，好吧，你可以把那个混蛋盖起来。你的车不是车轮上的政府广告牌。但事实证明，关于车牌的宪法之争
plates is not over because after all that was settled, a new problem showed up. Specialty plates. You've seen these. Unlike vanity plates where drivers choose their own numbers and letters, specialty plates sport alternate designs with their own logos and slogans. They're usually put out in collaboration with the government by a non-governmental organization. When drivers choose a specialty plate, they pay a little extra. And those proceeds get split between their chosen group and the State Department of Motor Vehicles. So for example, in my family, we have a Save the Manatees license plate. That's a specialty license plate that the state of Florida offers that we paid extra money to purchase.
并没有结束，因为在这一切尘埃落定之后，一个新的问题出现了。特色车牌。你见过这些。与车主选择自己数字和字母的个性化车牌不同，特色车牌拥有带有自己标志和标语的替代设计。它们通常是由非政府组织与政府合作推出的。当驾驶员选择特色车牌时，他们会支付额外的费用。这些收入将在他们选择的集团和州机动车辆管理局之间进行分配。例如，在我的家会，我们有一个“拯救海牛”车牌。那是佛罗里达州提供的特色车牌，我们花额外的钱购买了它。
Why did you choose the manatee plate? What are ridiculous questions we want to save humanity, naturally. Specialty plates are easy money. A lot of states will issue one to almost any nonprofit, as long as enough people are interested. But the problem with an open door policy is you might not like who comes inside. And a decade ago, the state of Texas learned that the hard way. I'm now calling the meeting for November 10, 2011 at the board of the Texas Department of Motor Vehicles to order. Usually public hearings for the DMV
你为什么选择海牛车牌？多么荒谬的问题，我们当然想拯救人类。特色车牌是轻而易举的钱。只要有足够多的人感兴趣，许多州会向几乎任何非营利组织发行一张。但开放大门政策的问题在于，你可能不会喜欢进来的人。十年前，德克萨斯州通过艰难的方式学到了这一点。我现在宣布2011年11月10日德克萨斯州机动车辆管理局董事会会议开幕。通常车管所的公开听证会
are dull bureaucratic affairs, poorly attended. But in 2011, the board of the Texas DMV held a standing room only hearing. So we're going to move to agenda item 5a, which is the approval of specially licensed plate. The DMV board votes unproposed designs for specialty plates. They generally approve the designs with very little fanfare or scrutiny. But this one was different.
是枯燥的官僚事务，出席人数很少。但在2011年，德克萨斯州车管所董事会举行了一场座无虚席的听证会。所以我们要转到议程项目5a，即特色车牌的批准。车管所董事会对特色车牌的提议设计进行投票。他们通常以很少的声势或审查批准这些设计。但这次不同。
The sons of Confederate veterans wanted Texas to issue a license plate featuring the Confederate battle flag. And a lot of people weren't happy about it. Dozens of community leaders showed up to testify. Good morning. Thank you very much for letting me come. That voice you're hearing is San Fronia Thompson. She's a Texas State House representative and a black woman born in 1939.
邦联老兵之子希望德克萨斯州发行一枚印有邦联战旗的车牌。很多人对此并不高兴。数十名社区领袖到场作证。早上好。非常感谢你们让我来。你听到的那个声音是桑弗尼亚·汤普森。她是德克萨斯州众议院议员，也是一位1939年出生的黑人女性。
There was a time that I could not even come on the grounds of the Capitol because I was black. And it's very difficult to be able to see these symbols because they bring back memories. And to me, it's like sticking poop in the face of black people every day to see them. That's how repulsive it is. We have folks who say, well, I'm offended by the SCV plate. And my response is, and your point? In favor of the Confederate flag plates,
曾几何时，我甚至不能踏上国会大厦的土地，因为我是黑人。要看到这些符号是非常困难的，因为它们会勾起回忆。对我来说，这就像每天把大便塞到黑人脸上一样，看到它们。就是这么令人反感。我们有些人说，好吧，我对SCV车牌感到被冒犯。我的回应是，所以呢？赞成邦联旗车牌的是
was Jerry Patterson. He's the commissioner of the Texas Land Office and a member of the Sons of Confederate Veterans. No one has a right to go through life to be unaffended. Patterson made a first amendment argument. He thought that if enough people like him wanted a specialty plate related to Texas history Then the state shouldn't be allowed to prevent him from having it. There's also some folks who suggested well now
杰里·帕特森。他是德克萨斯州土地局局长，也是邦联老兵之子的成员。没有人有权利在生活中不受冒犯。帕特森提出了第一修正案的论点。他认为，如果像他这样有足够多的人想要一个与德克萨斯历史相关的特色车牌，那么州就不应该被允许阻止他拥有它。还有一些人建议，现在
If you want to do that happen a Mexican flag plate and I say bring it on and if that plate offended anyone My response to them is well get a grip It's gonna happen as it should be After two hours of tense testimony, the board held its vote. All those in favor of denying the plate, please raise your right hand. All those opposed, the motion carries unanimously the plate is denied. There would not be a Texas license plate featuring a Confederate flag. But then the sons of Confederate veterans sued. Arguing that the state had violated their free speech rights by targeting speech that
如果你想这么做，那就搞一个墨西哥国旗车牌，我说放马过来，如果那个我对他们的回应是，好吧，振作起来。这将会发生，正如它应该发生的那样。经过两个小时紧张的听证会，董事会进行了投票。所有赞成拒绝该车牌的人，请举起你们的右手。所有反对的人，动议获得全票通过，车牌被拒绝。德克萨斯州不会出现印有邦联旗帜的车牌。但随后邦联老兵之子起诉了。他们辩称，州政府通过针对他们不喜欢的言论，侵犯了他们的言论自由权。
they did not like. Remember, Texas had an open door policy on specialty plates, which meant that they weren't normally in the business of picking sides. So the state really was singling out the sons of Confederate veterans when it denied their plate. And once again, there was a lot at stake here.
记住，德克萨斯州对特色车牌采取的是开放大门政策，这意味着他们通常不干预选边站队。因此，在拒绝其车牌时，该州确实是在挑出邦联老兵之子。又一次，这里有很多利害关系。
George Maynard's Live For Your Die Case had established that you could reject the state's messaging if it didn't suit you, but was it okay if the state to reject your message on a state issued license plate? We'll get to the argument first this morning in case 14144. So in 2015, license plates were back in the Supreme Court. John Walker versus the Texas Division of the Sons of Confederate Veterans. This was a really close decision, a five-fourth split. But the court's majority sided with Texas.
乔治·梅纳德的“不自由毋宁死”案已经确立了如果你不喜欢你可以拒绝州的信息传递，但州拒绝你在州发行车牌上的信息可以吗？我们将在今天早上的案子14144中首先听取辩论。所以在2015年，车牌再次回到了最高法院。约翰·沃克诉德克萨斯州邦联老兵之子分会案。这是一场非常势均力敌的裁决，以五比四的分裂。但法院多数派站在了德克萨斯州一边。
The state could deny the Confederate flag plates. The court acknowledged Jerry Patterson's right to display symbols, even abhorrent ones, on say a bumper sticker. But they said that right does not extend to license plates. Because the Supreme Court held that specialty license plates were government speech. And the government's right to speak is also protected. Justice Stephen Breyer, in his opinion, actually pointed to a kind of legal symmetry with the
州可以拒绝邦联旗车牌。法院承认杰里·帕特森展示符号的权利，甚至是令人厌恶的符号，比如在保险杠贴纸上。但他们表示，这种权利不延伸到车牌。因为最高法院裁定特色车牌是政府言论。政府说话的权利也受到保护。大法官史蒂芬·布雷尔在意见中实际上指出了与
live-free or die case, just like a state can't force an individual to display a message. So, the sons of Confederate veterans cannot force Texas to convey on its license plates, a message with which the state does not agree. Ultimately, the Supreme Court's decision in George Maynard's case didn't resolve all the issues around license plates, and neither will the Texas decision. Caroline Mollekorban thinks license plates will always be a contested space. A government-issued document displayed on a private vehicle.
“不自由毋宁死”案的一种法律对称性，就像州不能强迫个人展示信息一样。因此，邦联老兵之子不能强迫德克萨斯州在其车牌上传达一个该州不同意的信息。最终，最高法院对乔治·梅纳德案的裁决并没有解决围绕车牌的所有问题，德克萨斯州的裁决也不会。卡罗琳·马拉·科尔宾认为车牌将永远是一个有争议的空间。私人车辆上展示的政府发行文件。
It's as if a license plate is a kind of bowl horn, only instead of taking turns speaking. You have both the government and private individuals shouting into the bowl horn. The problem is they're both speaking. And perhaps that's why this little hunk of metal has so often become an ideological battleground. A place for governments and citizens to clash over the identity of an entire state in its attempt to reduce it to a slogan
这就像车牌是一种扩音器，只是不是轮流说话。政府和个人都在向扩音器里大喊大叫。问题是他们都在说话。也许这就是为什么这小块金属经常成为意识形态战场的原因。一个让政府和公民为整个州身份发生冲突的地方，它试图将其简化为一个标语
ensemble speeding down the highway. And those debates are still playing out. The Supreme Court ruling empowered Texas to keep the Confederate flag off its license plates, but it also empowered states to make the opposite choice, and at least six have. If you live in South Carolina, Mississippi, Alabama, Louisiana, Georgia, or Tennessee, you can go to your local DMV today and register your car with a state-issued specialty plate bearing a Confederate battle flag. In a couple of those states, Tennessee and South Carolina, lawmakers have actually introduced bills that would ban the flag from specialty plates.
在高速公路上呼啸而过。这些辩论仍在继续。最高法院的裁决授权德克萨斯州将邦联旗排除在车牌之外，但也授权各州做出相反的选择，至少有六个州这样做了。如果你住在南卡罗来纳州、密西西比州、阿拉巴马州、路易斯安那州、佐治亚州或田纳西州，你今天可以去当地的车管所，用带有邦联战旗的州发行特色车牌注册你的汽车。在其中的几个州，田纳西州和南卡罗来纳州，议员们实际上已经提出了法案，禁止在特色车牌上使用该旗帜。
But so far, neither bill has gotten a vote. And in Idaho, although it might not ever make it to the U.S. Supreme Court, the state's official license plate still raises eyebrows. In Idaho, although it might not ever make it to the US Supreme Court, the state's official license plate still raises eyebrows. And, you know, I wish we would change it. And some folks, like Rick Just, are still less than happy about it. I don't think that anybody really thinks it's a bad evil thing or anything, but, you know, I'm just tired of it.
但到目前为止，两项法案都没有获得投票。在爱达荷州，尽管它可能永远不会进入美国最高法院，但该州的官方车牌仍然让人侧目。在爱达荷州，尽管它可能永远不会进入美国最高法院，但该州的官方车牌仍然让人侧目。而且，你知道，我希望我们能改变它。有些人，比如里克·贾斯特，对此仍然不太高兴。我不认为任何人真的认为这是一个糟糕的邪恶事情什么的，但是，你知道，我只是厌倦了它。
There's no longer a lumpy brown spot on the license plate, but the motto still reads, famous potatoes. When we come back, reporter Daniel Ackerman takes us into the subculture of license plate collectors. You knew they existed, they do exist. Let's stay with us. We ended up cutting out, but can you tell us more about them? Yeah, so amateur collectors are really the keepers of this history. There's not like a Smithsonian Museum
车牌上不再有肿块状的棕色斑点，但座右铭仍然写着“著名的土豆”。当我们回来时，记者丹尼尔·阿克曼带我们进入车牌收藏家的亚文化。你知道它们存在，它们确实存在。让我们留下来。我们最后中断了，但你能跟我们多讲讲他们吗？是的，所以业余收藏家真的是这段历史的守护者。没有像史密森尼博物馆那样的
of the American License Plate or anything like that. It's kind of like archived in the basements and addicts around the country. Yeah, exactly. And one of those archivists is Stuart Berg. I recently visited Stuart here in Boston to check out his collection, because he's been collecting since he was a kid in the 70s and he said he inherited his first plates from his grandfather.
美国车牌博物馆之类的地方。它有点像被归档在全国各地的地下室和阁楼里。是的，没错。其中一位档案管理员是斯图尔特·伯格。我最近在波士顿拜访了斯图尔特，看看他的收藏，因为他从70年代还是个孩子的时候就开始收集了，他说他从祖父那里继承了他的第一批车牌。
My grandfather had a lot of really cool old cars and there were 21 plates hanging in his garage and at one point I took them all down and I actually have every one of those plates except one today and the one that I got rid of dying to get back. So like every true collector, his collection is perpetually one item short. Yeah, although he has certainly made up for that missing plate in terms of volume, because at one point he told me his plate collection topped a hundred thousand. Whoa. How do you even accumulate that many plates?
我祖父有很多非常酷的老爷车，他的车库里挂着21个车牌，有一次我把它们都取了下来，事实上除了一个之外，我今天拥有所有这些车牌，而我扔掉的那一个渴望拿回来。所以就像每个真正的收藏家一样，他的收藏永远少一件物品。是的，尽管他在数量上肯定弥补了那个丢失的车牌，因为有一次他告诉我他的车牌收藏突破了十万。哇。你怎么能积累那么多车牌？
Roman, I wanted to know that too, but Stewart was pretty reluctant to give up his sources. Oh, I see. But when it was at its height, his plate collection, it was so thorough that, you know, in the classic car world, someone who wanted an accurate vintage plate to go with their vintage car they would just call up Stewart. And I wanted every year that if somebody said hey I need a three-digit plate from my Buick from 1931 can you can you get me one and I'd I'd have it. So when I went to visit Stewart we sat out on the pool deck near his condo because of COVID and he rolled out this wagon with two huge plastic tubs completely packed with plates.
罗曼，我也想知道，但斯图尔特很不情愿放弃他的来源。哦，我明白了。但在其鼎盛时期，他的车牌收藏是如此全面，以至于，你知道，在老爷车世界里，想要一个准确的复古车牌来搭配他们的老爷车的人会直接打电话给斯图尔特。我希望每一年，如果有人说嘿，我需要一块1931年别克的三位数车牌，你能帮我弄到一个吗，我就会有。所以当我拜访斯图尔特时，因为疫情，我们坐在他公寓附近的泳池甲板上，他推出了一辆装有两个巨大塑料桶的推车，里面完全塞满了车牌。
Each one was in his own little protective sleeve. And he just started pulling out and showing me some of his favorites, starting with some of the earliest state-issued license plates, which were from the first decade at the 1900s. And so what were those like? They were really fancy.
每一个都在它自己的小保护套里。他开始拉出来向我展示他的一些最爱，从1900年代第一个十年的最早的一些州发行车牌开始。那么那些是什么样的呢？它们非常华丽。
To me, they actually looked more like fine China than vehicle tags. That's because they were literally made of porcelain. Well, that seemed a little too fragile to go on a car. Like, how does that work? Yeah, well, he was actually pretty proud that he had some without any chips or dings in them.
对我来说，它们实际上看起来更像是精美的中国瓷器，而不是车辆标签。这是因为它们真的是用瓷器制作的。嗯，那看起来太脆弱了，不能放在车上。这怎么运作？是的，好吧，他其实很自豪他有一些没有任何缺口或划痕的车牌。
But keep in mind, at that time, only really rich people owned cars. Like, they weren't even that reliable as a mode of transport, but they were definitely a status symbol. And the license plates kind of played along. They were this smooth, cobalt blue with bold white numbering. And I can actually show you one of you'd like to see it.
但请记住，在那个时候，只有真正有钱的人才拥有汽车。它们作为一种交通工具甚至都不可靠，但它们绝对是身份的象征。车牌也有点配合。它们是这种光滑的钴蓝色，带有醒目的白色数字。如果你想看的话，我实际上可以给你看一个。
Yeah. It was a 1909 number five. Feel how heavy that is. Oh, yeah. It was registered to a number five. Feel how heavy that is. Oh yeah. It was registered to a James B. Sterns, 31 Pleasant Street and Brooklyn Mass for a three horsepower Pope Electric. A Pope Electric, what's a Pope Electric?
好。那是1909年的数字5。感觉一下有多重。哦，是的。它注册在一个数字5上。感觉一下有多重。哦，是的。它注册在詹姆斯·B·斯特恩斯名下，地址是布鲁克林马萨诸塞州普莱森特街31号，是一辆三马力的波普电动车。波普电动车，什么是波普电动车？
It's an electric car. Oh, okay, there you go. So, I mean, this is before combustion took over. They were still experimenting with all these different types of engines. That's how new the automobile was at the time. Oh time. So I don't know if you caught that, but the license plate number was just five as in Massachusetts fifth state license plate. That is remarkable. Having license plate number five has got to confer some bragging rights in the license plate collection community.
这是一辆电动车。哦，好吧，原来如此。所以，我的意思是，这是在内燃机接管之前。他们仍在试验所有这些不同类型的发动机。当时的汽车就是这么新。哦时间。所以不知道你有没有注意到，车牌号只是5，就像马萨诸塞州的第五个州车牌。这太了不起了。拥有车牌号5一定能在车牌收藏界带来一些吹牛的权利。
Right. It absolutely does. And at the time, it also conferred bragging rights to the owner, like James P. Sterns, he was a bank president, so he was, you know, kind of the high society at the time. And Stuart also had first lady Francis Cleveland's license plate married to President Grover Cleveland, and she was number 44. 44, it's pretty good. But I did get the the era of fancy porcelain plates with low numbers didn't didn't last all that long. No. And that's thanks mainly to Henry Ford and his model T.
对。绝对是的。在当时，它也为车主带来了吹牛的权利，比如詹姆斯·P·斯特恩斯，他是一家银行的行长，所以他你知道的，有点像当时的社会名流。斯图尔特还拥有第一夫人弗朗西斯·克利夫兰的车牌，她嫁给了格罗弗·克利夫兰总统，她是第44号。44号，挺不错的。但我明白，带有低数字的华丽瓷牌时代并没有持续太久。不。这主要归功于亨利·福特和他的T型车。
Cars got way more affordable in the 19 teens. And in the first quarter of the century, the number of registered cars in the US jumped from 8,000 to more than 18 million. So as early as 1916, Massachusetts was stamping their plates out of tin, which was way cheaper. So these mass produced metal plates, they hit the scene. And that's when, you know, lights and plates, as we talk about in the story, basically become billboards. Right.
在20世纪10年代，汽车变得实惠得多。在本世纪的头二十五年里，美国注册汽车的数量从8,000辆跃升至1800万辆以上。因此早在1916年，马萨诸塞州就开始用锡冲压车牌，这便宜得多。所以这些大批量生产的金属车牌登场了。就在那时，你知道的，车牌，正如我们在故事中谈到的，基本上变成了广告牌。对。
They become the space where states can play around with graphics and slogans and steward has thousands of examples. So during our interview, he was pulling out plate after plate after plate. Like I would try to ask him a question and he would throw off a one word answer but already be pulling out the next graphic plate to show me. This is a golden Jubilee from the state of Washington from 1939.
它们成了各州可以玩弄图形和标语的空间，斯图尔特有数千个例子。所以在我们的采访中，他一直在拿出车牌。就像我试图问他一个问题，他会用一个字回答，但已经在拿出下一个图形车牌展示给我看。这是华盛顿州1939年的金禧纪念。
The 36 Wyoming was the first year of the Bucking Bronco. Mount Rushmore in 1952 was on the place the first year of the state shaped plate in Tennessee. So Carolina in 1930, they're the iodine state. And they like produce iodine? Yeah, it is the New York world's fair. No real graphics, but it does have a lot of words on it. Wow.
36年的怀俄明州是腾跃野马的第一年。1952年的拉什莫尔山在车牌上，那是田纳西州州形车牌的第一年。1930年的南卡罗来纳州，他们是碘州。他们生产碘吗？是的，这是纽约世界博览会。没有真正的图形，但它确实有很多字。哇。
It's kind of fun to hear all the experimentation that was going on. Like the Tennessee plate was shaped like Tennessee. That's pretty cool. Yeah, he said that one was actually pretty tough to mount on people's cars. It bet. Yeah, but you know that experimentation really exploded
听到所有正在进行的试验感觉很有趣。比如田纳西州的车牌形状像田纳西州。那挺酷的。是的，他说那个实际上很难安装在人们的车上。我敢说。是的，但你知道这种试验确实爆发了
in the 1970s when states started putting a reflective coating on the license plates. And that basically let them print really detailed graphics rather than having to like emboss the shapes into the metal. So design's got really busy. And I think that is perhaps best exemplified by the plates that Illinois recently introduced just back in 2017. So let's pull that one up.
在20世纪70年代，当各州开始在车牌上涂上反光涂层时。这基本上让他们可以打印非常详细的图形，而不必把形状压印到金属中。所以设计变得非常忙碌。我认为这或许可以由伊利诺伊州在2017年刚刚推出的车牌最好地体现出来。所以让我们把那个拿出来。
Oh yeah, okay. So there's a lot going on here. Yeah. It has the light blue and red of the Chicago flag, which I like. That looks like the top of the state house, I'm assuming. And then a windmill. Yeah, shout out to rural Illinois. Yeah, because right next to that is the Chicago skyline. And then of course, at the very far left edge is a half a face of Abraham Lincoln.
哦，是的，好吧。所以这里有很多事情正在发生。是的。它有我喜欢的芝加哥国旗的浅蓝色和红色。看起来像州议会大厦的顶部，我猜。然后是一个风车。是的，向乡村伊利诺伊州致敬。是的，因为旁边就是芝加哥天际线。然后当然，最左边边缘是亚伯拉罕·林肯的一半脸。
Right. So there's not even enough room for him. He's like split right down the nose. And it has land of Lincoln, of course, which is their motto. What's kind of interesting about this is like, this is kind of the opposite of the Idaho potato problem that we talked about in the piece. I mean, this is not the whole state boiled down into one thing. This is the whole state boiled down into way too many things to put on a license plate.
对啊。所以连他的空间都不够。他的脸直接从鼻子中间被分开了。上面当然还写着“林肯故乡”，这是他们的座右铭。这其中比较有趣的一点是，这有点像是我们在节目中讨论过的爱达荷州土豆问题的对立面。我的意思是，这并不是把整个州浓缩成一件事。而是把整个州浓缩成了太多东西，根本无法塞进一个车牌里。
Right. And you know, it's not pretty because the, it's not like the canvas gets any bigger. It's still just this half a square foot and you're cramming ever more onto it. And so what do, you know, people extur, you know, license plate collectors make of, you know, this kind of graphical onslaught, you know, like, what do they think of this as compared to the old plates? Yeah, I mean, most collectors I talked to expressed a preference for those older plates
没错。你知道的，这并不好看，因为画布并没有变大。它依然只有半平方英尺那么大，而你却往上面塞了越来越多的东西。所以，你知道的，车牌收藏家们对这种图形的狂轰滥炸怎么看？与旧车牌相比，他们是怎么看待这种设计的呢？对吧，我的意思是，我交谈过的大多数收藏家都表示更喜欢那些旧车牌
with the simple sleek design, but a lot of them also just take the whole thing in stride because to guys like Stewart, the more the merrier, right? Do you think license plate design has gotten like too busy and complicated? No, I don't. Here's a knee plate. This is one of my favorites.
设计简洁流畅，但他们中的许多人也对这一切泰然处之，因为对斯图尔特这样的人来说，多多益善，对吧？你觉得车牌设计变得太繁复、太复杂了吗？不，我不觉得。给你看一个新车牌。这是我最喜欢的车牌之一。
It's the Georgia peach. What else do I have that I can show you? More graphics just means more plates. It just means more joy for Stuart. Absolutely, yes. Just more grist for the collector's mill. Is it Texas Centennial Plate from 1936? Is New Mexico 1940? Great graphics on these.
这是佐治亚州的桃子。我还有什么可以给你看的？更多的图形意味着更多的车牌。这也意味着斯图尔特会有更多的快乐。完全正确，是的。这只是为收藏家的磨坊提供了更多原料。这是1936年的得克萨斯州百年纪念车牌吗？这是1940年的新墨西哥州车牌。这些车牌上的图案真棒。
Utah Center, Cena, America in 1942. Ohio in 1938. A early graphic plate from Rhode Island. 41 Hawaii is an Oklahoma plate with an F and the S. And this is a very, very red plate. 99% of visible was produced this week by Daniel Ackerman, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by our director of Sound Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is the senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, Ressa Teem
1942年的犹他州中心、塞纳、美利坚。1938年的俄亥俄州。罗得岛州早期的一个带图形的车牌。41年的夏威夷州是一个带有F和S的俄克拉荷马州车牌。这是一个非常非常红的车牌。99% Invisible 本周由 Daniel Ackerman 制作，Joe Rosenberg 编辑，Bryson Barnes 混音，音乐由我们的声音总监 Sean Rial 创作。Delaney Hall 是高级制作人，Kurt Colstead 是数字总监，Ressa Teem
is Emmett Fitzgerald, Katie Mingle, Christopher Johnson, Abby Medon, Chris Baroupe, Vivian Leye, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to a whole bunch of additional people we interviewed for this story, including Virginia Sharf, Eugene Volok, Peter Blodget, Dan Smith, Thomas Wilson, and especially Tennessee State Representative, G.A. Hardaway, who is fighting to get the Confederate Battle Flag off of the state's specialty plates. If you want to learn more about all of this, we'll have links and media on our website, 9iPi.org. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is spread across all of North America right now,
是 Emmett Fitzgerald、Katie Mingle、Christopher Johnson、Abby Medon、Chris Baroupe、Vivian Leye、Sophia Klatsker，还有我 Roman Mars。本周我们要特别感谢为这个故事接受我们采访的许多其他人，包括 Virginia Sharf、Eugene Volok、Peter Blodget、Dan Smith、Thomas Wilson，尤其是田纳西州众议员 G.A. Hardaway，他一直在努力将邦联战斗旗从该州的特色车牌上去掉。如果你想了解更多关于这一切的信息，我们将在我们的网站 9iPI.org 上提供链接和多媒体内容。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于 Radio Row，它目前分布在整个北美洲，
but is centered in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting, discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI-org or on Instagram and read it too. But if you want to chime in on which state has the best license plate, well, I encourage you to speak your piece at 9iPI.org. Video til the end.
但以美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为中心。我们是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最棒、最具创新性节目的联盟，你可以在 radiotopia.fm 发现、收听并支持他们所有节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我（Roman Mars），也可以 @ 本节目 99PIorg，或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但是，如果你想就哪个州拥有最好的车牌发表意见，嗯，我鼓励你在 9iPI.org 上发表你的看法。视频直到最后。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。